Hi, everyone. Welcome back.
I am Dr. Matthew Heller.
I am excited to be giving
you all another lecture.
So we are going to talk about
orthopedic concerns
of the spine.
So we had two prior
lectures. If you guys
are going out of order,
this may be your first
one. If you're going
in order, this will
be your third of three
orthopedic lectures.
We had the lower extremity
presented by one of our
academic scholars. Very,
very well done. And then
we have the lower
extremities, and today we will
be talking about orthopedic
concerns of the spine.
So I am a NICOM
full-time faculty,
went to NICOM, did a
family medicine, sports
medicine fellowship,
family medicine residency.
If you all have any
questions for me,
here is my email
address right over here.
And, um, again, we're going
to take out Larry the Bird,
right, it's now X, so,
um,
any questions, let me know.
Hopefully, I'm going to
make this a fun lecture,
right, because a lot of
this stuff that we talk
about is very, very relevant,
and I think that no matter
what field you go into,
right, um, you're still
going to get the patient
that's coming in with
neck pain and back pain,
So whether you
are in geriatric,
pediatric, internal
medicine, OBGYN,
surgery, whatever is
surgical, non-surgical,
somebody is always
going to ask you about
their back pain. It's
just a very, very
common complaint that
you're going to see.
And we're going to talk
more about the history in
the DPR lecture on getting
a history with somebody
with back pain and the
physical exam skills. but
today we're going to
talk a lot more about the
pathology and some of the
orthopedic intervention.
So today's objective is
we're going to talk about
bony and short tissue injuries
to the cervical spine.
We're going to talk about
complications that's
related to the cervical
spine. We're going to talk
about management options
in any spinal injuries.
We're going to talk about
bone and short tissue
injuries to the lumbar
spine. So again cervical,
now lumbar. We're going
to talk about urgent
versus emergent, right,
spinal conditions, and
we're going to talk about
interpreting clinical
signs and symptoms of
spine pathology. And then,
of course, there's a
little surprise at the end.
So who are we and
who am I presenting
to? We've got the
Red Wolf down in
Joan Burrell, so
hello to Joan Burrell.
And we have the New York
Tech Bears, right? A very
new logo, about maybe seven
or eight years old, right?
Yes, so some of you
mentioned that you don't
like waiting until the
end to get a surprise, so
we put together a
video with the class of
2022, and you all remember
when you had your white
coat ceremony, right,
how cool that was, and
that is still a very,
very, very cool moment.
So hopefully you all
took some pictures.
The saying goes that
when you're a medical
student you wear a
short white coat,
when you're a
resident you wear a
long white coat,
and then when you're
an attending you
wear no white coat.
So if you see me in the clinic
usually I'm wearing a scrub.
So we asked the class of
2022 if you go back to
your white coat ceremony
and tell yourself something
What would you say?
Hi, I'm Ryan,
class of 2022.
If I could go back
to my white coat
ceremony, I would
tell myself to really
embrace the why of
every learning topic.
If I could go back and
tell myself something at
the white coat ceremony,
I would say the
struggles and the hardships
you face during medical
school will contribute
to who you are as a
person and your success
as a future position. to
keep up in mind because
there's so much you
can learn from listening
to the perspectives
of others but all
the while don't let
others influence you or
what you choose to do
hi i'm carl thank class
of 2022 if i could go back
to my white coat ceremony
i would tell myself
do not get discouraged
by a setback take a step
back we're welcome back
because today's setbacks
are just opportunities
for tomorrow's games this
is 2022 if i go back to
my white coat ceremony
So, some of you all may
be rotating with me at
some point in the clinic,
in the sports medicine,
family medicine, and family
medicine in the third
year, sports medicine in
the fourth year. So, we'll
be making, we could
possibly make a video and
you guys will be putting
that into the lecture for
our class of, it'll
probably be class of 28, 29,
30, 31. Wow, this class
of 2031 when you all are
fourth years, and they
will be your first years.
But we need to get on to
the lecture itself, right?
So we're going to talk
about spine pain, right? So
we're going to talk about
back pain, neck pain, history,
physical exam, talk about
imaging, right? Talk about
lab, some few definitions,
right? You're going to
get an MRI report. You got
to know certain terminology
or an x-ray, know certain
terminology. We're going
to talk about cervical
orthopedic disorders, and we
will talk about the thoracic
lumbar orthopedic disorders.
We're going to talk about
the very, very mild pain,
sort of more severe and
more complicated as well.
When we talk about
getting an OP-QRSC, when
we talk about pain,
getting a chief complaint,
the most common chief
complaint for the spine is
they're going to say, Doc,
I have pain, right, whether
the pain's in the neck,
the pain's in the back, and
there's different types
of pain, and that's really
where you're going to go
through your PCOS-C, right?
Like, for example,
radiation of the pain, is it
radiating to the lower
extremities, is it radiating
anything to the arm, right?
That's going to tell you
that you have a radiculopathy
type of pain, right? So
a radicular pain, right? So
you're going to have some
kind of herniated disc
or maybe spinal stenosis,
right? You want to know
the quality of the pain. Is
it a sharp shooting pain
or is it a dull, achy pain,
right? Was it getting
better? What makes it worse?
Onset? How long is it
going on for? These
types of questions are
going to help differentiate
what type of pain
you're dealing with.
You also want to
know the associated
symptoms, whether there's
anything systemic.
Red flag symptoms.
We're going to
talk a lot about
red flag symptoms.
You have somebody with
severe back pain and they
have a fever and they
have a history of weight
loss. This is all systemic.
This is all something
that might be needed to be
more urgently evaluated.
You're going to be asking about
systemic,
neurological symptoms,
any trauma history,
what kind of work do
they do, different job
occupations can play a role
in back pain, whether they're
sedentary, sitting down
for 9-10 hours a day,
versus recreational activities.
So, we're going to
go more specific into
the physical exam
during the DPR lecture.
So highly
recommended, make sure
they attend the DPR lectures,
and especially the DPR
lecture of the hip and
knee that took many,
many hours to put
together, but I think you
are all going to enjoy.
So like we do everything
else, we always want to
inspect, right? Look at the
patient, right? Look at where
they're pointing the pain.
Is anything abnormal about
that area, right? See how
they're walking in, right?
Are they walking with a
limp, are they walking
with a cane, are they
walking with a walker? right,
palpate the spine, range
of motion, neurological
assessment of the trunk
and extremities, and if
you're evaluating neck
pain, cervical pain,
right, examine the shoulder,
right, if you're checking
out the lumbar, lower
back, examine the hip
and the lower extremities,
and special testing.
So at some point you're going
to be asked to order some
imaging, and it's always
good to know what kind of
imaging you want to order,
right, usually the most
specific, the most common right
the first choice of imaging
is going to be the x-ray
and why are we doing an x
-ray because we want to take
a look at the bone right
x-ray is not going to show
you too much about the soft
tissue or or any kind of
herniation or whatever else
might be causing pain but
at least you're going to get
a good image of what the
bones look like right is
there are three exchanges in
the bone are they bone spurs
are they calcification uh
we're going to be able to
identify if there's any acute
fractures right so x-ray
is usually going to be your
first imaging of choice
right somebody comes in,
severe pain, and it's going
on, and they try conservative
management, and it's still
not getting any better,
right, then, and they don't,
well, initially they didn't
have any red flags, but
now the pain's not going
away, or now they develop red
flag symptoms, right, you're
going to get the x-ray.
If you want more specific
on the bone anatomy,
right, you may consider
getting a CAT scan, right,
this is used more for like
pre-op planning, post-op
evaluation and then any
kind of trauma, right? So
if somebody comes in, multi
-trauma, into the trauma
room, right? You may
consider getting a cast scan
because you're not going to
want to wait for the MRI,
right? You're going to
want to get the cast scan,
get a better evaluation of
the bone, right? And then
the MRI, right? So after
you get the x-ray, right?
Whatever changes you
see, now you get the MRI.
Now you have a better
stress history resolution,
And this is good for any
kind of herniation, disc
herniation, degenerative
disc, any kind of
spinal stenosis, any
ligament, tumor, infection,
MRI is going to be your
better imaging of choice.
Then we also have the
bone scan, right, the bone
scan, it's a nuclear medicine
test, uses radioactive
traces, right, and that
basically locate areas
of increased metabolic
activity, right. So sometimes
you may have, like, a
stress fracture, right?
You think it's a stress
fracture, but nothing's
showing up on the x-ray,
but you palpate the bone,
and it's very, very tender,
right? A bone scan is
going to help show that
area of increased metabolic
activity, right? It's
also going to help with
metastatic disease, any
kind of infection that might
be showing the same
increased metabolic activity.
We also have blood
testing. You may want
to consider if you
think it's an infection,
right?
CBC is taking a weight
count. If you think it's
inflammatory, you may want to
get a CRP or an ESR, right?
And then there's also a
SPEP and a UPEP, which is
basically a test that really
separates the protein,
the proteins within the
blood by their electrical
charges, right? And what they
do is it gives you a better
measurement of potential
different types of myeloma
if they have any kind of
pathology in that direction,
right? So if you
think there's any kind
of plasma cell disorder,
right, or myeloma,
right, S-PEP and U
-PEP would be, and S
-PEP and U-PEP, basically,
S is for serum,
meaning blood, and
U is for urine,
right, and then
protein electrophoresis
is what PEP stands
for, so serum,
protein
electrophoresis.
The first injury we're
going to talk about,
well, the first pathology
is cervical sprain,
cervical strain. So the
history, again, is very
important, and when you
get into the history
of the patient, you want
to know when did the
pain begin. If it began
after a car accident,
oops, sorry, if the pain
began after a car accident
or they had some kind
of whiff-blast injury
with an acceleration
-deceleration injury, that's
something you're going
to want to note down, and
potentially that could
be the cause of the pain.
So basically the soft
tissue activity threshold
is surpassed, so the
amount of force acting
on the soft tissue is
greater, and many of the
cervical muscles do not
terminate in tendon,
but they attach directly
to the periosteum.
So the muscles are tassids,
so there's no muscle
tendon bone like we
normally see. right,
there's muscle to the
periocteum, right, so the
muscle responds to the
injury by contracting,
right, and then it
goes into a neck spasm,
and then you're going
to have specific finding
that you're going to
see on x-ray, which
we're going to show x
-rays in the next slide.
Findings is going to
be a very non-focal,
non-radiating type of
neck pain, right, they're
going to have a spasm
in their neck, it's
going to feel like a
spasm in their neck,
they're going to have decreased
range of motion, they're
going to try to move their
head to the left, and as
they're moving their head
to the left, they're going
to look like they're very
hesitant to move their head
to the left, or to the
right, or up and down, right?
They're going to have
that decreased range of
motion. They're going to
have upper back and shoulder
gurgle pain as well,
and that can be
associated with
occipital headache,
occipital neuralgia,
I guess the medical
term, right? But
they're going to have a
headache that goes along
with the neck pain,
right? More tension
headache, potentially,
right? But the main
thing is, they're
going to have spasm
of the paraspinal
muscles and the
trapezius muscle.
So we're going to treat
this basically by, if
they're an athlete, we're
going to keep them out of
any kind of contact sport
activity, and we wouldn't
want them playing in a
football game, right? So
we want to prevent any
further injuries to what
they already have, all
right? Especially if they're
looking to, some of them
may be looking to get
back on the field a lot
quicker. We want to make
sure that the pain goes
away, the pain is sustainable
before we can get them
back onto the field.
So, and then we just want
to monitor the symptom
conservative management
from the beginning,
right, and then we try
all conservative and
then if that's not working,
right, then we consider
potentially surgical.
But at this point it
very, very rarely gets
to this at this point.
So again, the surgical
is very, very rare,
usually there's going to
be more that goes along
with the pain, my disc
herniation, but we're
going to talk about
that in a few slides.
For this slide right here,
we're going to talk about
a typical, very typical,
wrist or accelerating
-deceleration injury, and
what happened is this is a
normal radiograph, right?
So you remember in probably
OMM lab or anatomy,
right, we talk about the
cervical lodosis, right?
Cervical lodosis, we have that
nice curve, but you may
read an x-ray result, or
you may look at the actual
x-ray because we always
look at the x-ray, and
you're going to know that
there's going to be a
flattening of the curve, right?
So you're going to flatten
out that curve, right?
So the curve's a lot flatter
than it is over here,
right? So flattening of
the curve, straightening
of the lordotic curve,
right, that's very typical
for somebody that has a
spasm within the neck,
right? Because of the muscle
spasm, right, the patient
is going to lose their
cervical lordosis. So
you're going to be able
to pick this up on x-ray.
In this case, you don't
necessarily need an MRI, right?
The MRI would only be
if, for some reason, they
have neurological symptoms
that goes along with this,
right? So if they have arm
pain or pain radiating down
into the arm or any kind
of signs of nerve, root,
and compression like weakness
or decreased sensation,
right, numbness,
then we would say,
you know what,
let's get an MRI.
But at this point,
if they're just having
a muscle spasm, you
wouldn't need to get
an MRI at this point.
Then we're going to talk
about cervical spondylolisis.
Spondylolisis, right?
So we're going to have a
lot of big words that
are very, very similar.
We're going to be
able to differentiate
them by the end of
the presentation.
So this is a chronic wear
and tear type of injury.
So it's more of a
wear and tear. I guess
you can't really
say injury because
it might not even be
a specific injury,
right? It's more something
that just happens
as we get older. As
we get older, right,
the disc is going to
become a little bit more
dehydrated, right? It's
going to have some more
wear and tear, and
that's going to cause it
to shrink a little bit,
right? You're going to
get associated arthritis
in the area, right?
and it's going to cause
the whole disc to become a
lot stiffer, right? It's
not going to be as flexible
as it was when we were younger,
right? And you're going
to get some aesthetic
changes in the neck as well,
right? So this results
in dysplogenic neck
pain. So this is
basically insidious onset
of neck pain without
any focal neurological
symptoms. So no focal
neurological symptoms,
right? And it's going
to be exacerbated by
vertebral motions. turning
your head to the left,
turning your head to the
right, and you're going
to be able to see the
expression on the patient's
face as they're turning
their head to the left,
they're going to hesitate
because they know
that certain movements
are going to be painful.
So those are all signs
that it's going to be
spondylolisis. And again, no
focal neurological symptoms.
And this is all part
of the discogenic neck
pain. So discogenic
neck pain is without
have focal neurological
symptoms, and I
repeat that because
it's going to progress,
right? So it can progress
in the more severe cases,
now you're going to get
neurological symptoms,
right? So what's going to
happen now is we're going to
have radiculopathy, right?
So we're going to have
radiculopathy, and this is
where you have unilateral, neck
and shoulder and arm pain,
right? You're going to have
parathisia, you're going to
have numbness exacerbated
by any kind of mechanical
stress on the nerve root.
We talked about
spelling tests, right?
We are going to practice
that again because
spelling tests are
a very common test.
Basically, it's
testing for any kind
of compression on
the nerve root.
So this is where you extend
the patient's neck, rotate
the head to the side,
and you apply an axial
compressing downward on top of
the head, picking up cervical
radiculopathy. So we
talked about cervical
radiculopathy, you're nilateral,
right, because it's impinging
on the nerve root, right,
it's going to progress
in the more severe
cases to myelopathy.
So myelopathy, myelopathy, the
difference is now
you have bilateral,
right, now you have something
impinging on the spinal cord,
right, so viseculopathy,
something's impinging
on the nerve root, now
you're having myelopathy,
you're impinging on
the spinal cord itself.
It could be many
things that could
be impinging on
the spinal cord.
It could be any kind of
castification, bone spurs,
it could be the
herniation, the
disc herniation.
So there's a number of things
that can impinge on the
spinal cord. You're going
to have bilateral weakness,
upper more than lower,
decreased manual dexterity.
Difficulty walking, sensation
going to be decreased,
fine motor skill
difficulty, you may
have some bowel,
bladder, incontinence.
So that's why we want
to ask them, are you
having any bowel,
bladder, incontinence?
If they say yes, it's
a red flag symptom.
So it's definitely
one of the things
we want to roll out
before we do any
further management.
So, here we have some radiograph,
right, so spondylolisis,
right, so basically the
middle picture you have
some bone spurs that lead
to narrowing of the canals,
right, so you can kind of
see that the bone spurs are
developing like right over
here, and what that's doing
that's impinging on the
spinal cord, right, so you can
kind of see it on, you can
see it on x-rays, you can
see it on different types
of imaging, but the MRI is
usually the best for picking
it up with the soft tissue.
We can kind of see
it over here as well.
So you can kind of
see the impingement
that it has on the spinal cord.
So again, radiculopathy
versus myelopathy.
Very important to
know the difference.
We're going to talk about
cervical disc disease.
And some of the
etiology, you have
degeneration of the
cervical spondylosis,
and that can come
from disc herniation.
So cervical disc
disease, now you have the
disc which is in
between the vertebrae.
So again, that can cause a
potential for disc herniation
that can impinge on the
nerve root via direct
compression. So now you have
something compressing on the
nerve root. It's going to
have radiculopathy type of
pain. It's going to affect
the nerve root that's below.
So C6, C7 is going to affect
C7. And the presentation
is going to be very similar
to cervical spondylosis.
So presentation is very
similar to spondylosis. We
talked about the axial neck
pain, low-grade stiffness
and worse with any kind
of extension of the neck.
It could potentially lead to
radiculopathy or myelopathy.
So this is a very
important picture, and I
put this in here because
it's very important.
So basically we know that
one of the things we need
to keep in mind is that
the cervical spine and the
lumbar spine, right, they
have some key differences.
One of the key differences
we need to know
is that in the cervical
spine, the nerve
root comes out in a
horizontal direction.
So we talked about before,
well, we didn't talk
about it, but we can talk
about it now is that
our C6 nerve root is
going to come over on
top of the C6 pedicle.
So this goes all the
way down the cervical
spine, and then it
changes up when we have
the C8.
So we have the C8 nerve
root, but we don't
have a C8 pedicle.
We don't have the C8
vertebra. So what's going
to happen is, so now
all the nerve roots
are coming out above.
So C6 is coming out, nerve root
is coming out above C6 pedicle.
What happened is, once
we get to the thoracic
area, now all the nerve
roots are going to come
out below it. So the
T1, the T1, right here
we have L4, and then we
have the nerve root L4.
The other key difference
we need to know about
this is that the nerve
root is going to drop
and then it's going
to come out over here.
So that's important to
know because if you have
an L4, L5 nerve root and
you have an L4, L5 disc
herniation, depending
on where the herniation
is, it's going to tell
you what type of pain
pattern you're going to
have. So if it's more
paracentral or if it's
posterior lateral, those are
the terminologies I use
almost interchangeable.
So if it's posterior
lateral or paracentral,
basically it's coming
out of the weaker part.
The herniation is happening out
of the weaker part of the disc.
And that's going to imping
on the nerve right below
it. Alright, so L4, L5 is
going to impinge right over
here, and that's going to
cause an L5 distribution,
right? If you do get a
herniation on the far lateral
disc, right? So you
have an L4, L5 on the
lateral, right? Now you're
going to have impingements
on the L4. So L4, L5 at
the far lateral is going
to cause an L4 nerve
pathology pattern, right?
So definitely worth taking
a look over this a couple
of times and making sure
that you understand.
If you have any
questions, let me know.
But you can kind of
see this from the
picture. Again, let's
show that one more time.
This is the L5. It's
going to come down,
and it's going to come
out underneath L5.
So I'm repeating this
again just to see if I can
say it a little bit
different. So if L5 is coming
down, so if it's paracentral,
it's going to have the
injury, it's going to have
the impingement. So L4,
L5 disc herniation is
going to impinge on the L5.
But if it's on the
outside, if the herniation
of the disc is on the
outside, chances are
higher that it's going
to impinge on the L4, L4.
So in the lumbar, we
have two different
potential, L4, L5 can
affect L4 or L5. Most
commonly, it's going
to be L5 because that's
the paracentral or
the posterior lateral.
That's the most common because
that's the weakest
part of the disc.
If you talk about C6, C7,
whether it's on the inside,
closer to the central,
or it's on the lateral.
So whether it's
central or lateral, C6,
C7 is going to imping
on the same nerve root.
So C67 is, whether it's
lateral or central,
it's going to impinge on
that same nerve root. When
I talk about impinge, we're
talking about a
disc herniation.
So disc herniation is
usually going to go along
the weaker part of the
disc. In that case,
it's going to be the
posterior lateral or the
paracentral. So here, it's
going to come out, and
what's going to be
right there is the nerve
root. right, you can see
that close proximity,
right, that's going to
cause impingements on
the nerve root, and
that's going to cause the
unilateral pain that
goes all the way down,
right, so inside the, on
the inside, right, we're
going to have, I'm going
to have a better diagram
before, right, we're going to
have the nucleus propulsus,
right, the NP, and then
you're going to have annular
fibers that's on the
outside, so this is all AF,
annular fibers, right, but
we have another slide in
a little bit that's going
to have a better picture,
but I just wanted to show
you while we're talking
about disc herniation,
what we're looking at.
Here's another picture,
you can see the disc
herniation is impending
on the nerve root.
So we talk about cervical
disc disease, so we
talk about something
impending on the nerve root.
So when something impends
on the nerve root, it's
going to have a unilateral
pain, or it's going
to have unilateral
decreased sensation, or it's
going to have unilateral
and or unilateral decrease
reflexes, chances are
it's going to have all
three if it's a true
impingement on the nerve.
So this is important
to know, and not
just for me but for
first aid and for
every exam you take
for a long time,
is to know C5, C6,
and C7, and C8, they all have
different distribution pattern.
So I have some more pictures.
More pictures. We'll look
at this in a little bit.
Actually, we could
talk about it now
as well. So C5, the
motor is going to be
deltoid. It's going
to be coming up.
C5 is also going to
have the bicep reflex.
And you're going
to have decreased
sensation on the
lateral upper arm.
So that's C5. We go to
C6. We go in order. C6 is
going to have weakness
in the... C6 you're going
to have the bicep tendon.
I have... disregard
what I just said. So C6 is
the reflex on the varicose
radialis. You're going
to have wrist extension
weakness and you're
going to have the bicep
weakness as well. So there
might be some overlap.
Different resources, you're
going to have different
specifics and it's going
to be the lateral forearm.
And then we're going to have
C7, tricep tendon reflex.
It's going to be more
towards the middle finger,
some of the inner neck
finger, some of the ring
finger, but definitely
the entire middle finger,
and the tricep is going
to be, the tricep and
the wrist flexion is
going to be weak as well.
And so C6, you have
wrist extension, and C7,
wrist flexion, and then
C8 as well, which there's
going to be weakness
to the distal phalanx.
Special testing, right,
for radiculopathy, right,
you're going to have
hyporeflexia. The reflexes are
going to be diminished and
asrophies are going to occur
because you're going to
have weakness. You're going
to look for a swelling
test, shoulder abduction
test. You're going to help
differentiate whether it's
a true cervical radiculopathy
or whether they're
just having issues with
their shoulders. So cervic
radiculopathy is usually
unilateral, and then we talked
about myelopathy which
is impending not just on
the nerve root but on the
spinal cord itself, and now
you have hyperreflexia. Now
the reflexes are increased.
You're going to have
positive Benvensky signs,
and there's some other
special testing that's going
to be positive if it's
impending on the spinal cord.
So here's another
diagram, this might be a
little bit more clear
than the other one.
So we mentioned C5 on
the upper arm, C6 comes
down to the lateral
forearm, C7 usually with the
middle finger and C8
usually on the ring finger.
Again, C5 for the bicep
tendon, C6 for the
brachial radialis,
and C7 is the tricep.
And the reason why
I'm showing you a
different diagram is
there's going to be subtle
differences between
different resources,
right, so not that one
resource is right and
another is not right.
It's just that there's
different observations,
different studies.
So when you see this on
an exam, it's not going
to be something that's
similar. We're going to make
it a little bit more
different between the two.
So here I put two
of them together.
So two pictures together.
Again, C5, you're going to
have weakness in the deltoid
and some in the bicep.
And then the bicep
reflexes in C5, C6 is going
to be more with the
brachial radialis, and C7
is going to be more with
the tricep reflexes.
So there's a lot of, I
don't know if there's a lot
of mnemonic, but I always
felt like mnemonic kind
of help you when you
have to remember so many
different things, right?
So one thing I kind of keep
in mind is for C7, right,
the way that we remember
that it's the middle finger,
you might not see this
down in jungle, but if
you guys are up in New
York, right, if you ever
cut anybody off on the LIE,
right, chances are pretty high
they're going to give you
the middle finger, right?
So if you think about that
aspect, right, where now
they give you the finger,
right, And how do they give
you the finger? They put
their hand out the window,
right? So when they
put their hand out
the window, what
are they extending,
right? They're extending
their triceps, right?
They're extending
their elbow, right? So
that's going to be a
motor for the triceps, and
then you're going to
have the triceps reflex.
Again, I don't think you
guys see this in Joanville,
but in New York, Long Island
Expressway, right, especially
on a busy day when it's
95 degrees out, right, cut
somebody off again, right?
So, just think about that
being for C7, right, they're
going to extend their arm
out the window, right, so
that's the extension, right,
then they're going to get
the reflexes on the elbow,
right, the tricep,
and then the middle
finger for C7, and
then, let's see,
so here we have the
tricep for reflex, tricep
for motor, and the
middle finger mostly for
the sensory loss.
And then C6, I said
this, but I say it over
and over again because
it's important stuff,
not just for now, but
for down the road.
C6, so it's
brachioridialis as well,
they're saying the
bicep, but one resource
is saying brachioridialis,
but if you,
there's going to be a
clear difference. That's
why it's good to know
the motor, the reflexes,
and the sensory. You can
put them all together,
right, so if they say
that the bicep is weak,
right, and then the
brachioradialis and the thumb
is affected, right,
it's going to be your C6
nerve root.
And even on real
patients, right,
patients will
present in different
in different patterns.
So it's good to know
the general nerve
root imaging. We're
going to get x
-rays. You can get
AP, lateral, oblique.
Caspian shows
ossification, foraminal
spinosis, and bony
cord compression.
MRI is the imaging
of choice for
cervical, thoracic,
and lumbar disease.
And I'll say that again,
MRI is always going to be
the imaging of choice for
cervical, thoracic, and lumbar
disease, test for spinal
cord lesions, as well as
any potential for like
infection, tumor, nerve
impingement, how do we treat
it conservatively, always
conservative before you do
surgical, and then if we need
to, depending on the type
of pain they're having,
then we will do a
surgical procedure.
So anti-inflammatory, rest,
ice, stop the activity
that's causing the
pain. right, some people
would say to try a soft
collar, right, physical
therapy is beneficial,
right, you learn exercises,
right, isometric exercise,
strengthen up the
neck muscles, and then if
you need to do surgery,
if you're getting progressive
neurological symptoms,
then you may want to
consider getting surgery.
Or if you have the
potential for any kind of
myelopathy, you have
impingements on the spinal
cord, and again, surgery
will be your option then.
So for surgery, different
surgical procedures,
right, you could do
the epidural steroid
injection. Basically,
you're taking steroids,
you're putting it right
into the epidural space.
You're doing that
with a needle, you're
doing that under
imaging, so that
we make sure we
get the right area.
And then we also
have the anterior
cervical discectomy
with the fusion or
you can do a total
disc replacement.
And again, this is
based on the type
of pain that they
may be experiencing.
90% of patients
with RA, rheumatoid
arthritis, have cervical
spine involvement.
They're going to have
neck pain, stiffness
and headache.
Neurological impairment
can occur, but it's
usually gradual.
One of the more common
etiologies, something very,
very important to remember
is that they have a
subluxation, you're going
to have an excessive amount
of movement between the
atlas and the atlas, and
what that's going to do is
it's going to build up a
panosformation between the
joint and it's going to
cause the destruction of
the transverse ligament.
Important to know,
that's why you have to
be careful if you have
a patient with RA.
You might notice in your
OMM lab that a lot of
patients with RA is a
contraindication for doing certain
techniques like cervical,
HVLA, so anything
that's going to cause a
sudden movement in the neck
because what's going to
happen is you're going to
have an absence of a
competent transverse ligament.
So in absence of a transverse
ligament that's competent,
you're going to be
setting yourself up or the
patient is going to
potentially have a complication
where the spinal cord is
compressed between C1 and C2.
Not a good thing,
causing paralysis of all
four limbs and it
could go up into the
medulla and potentially
leading to death.
So again, any manipulation
of the cervical
spine, you always got
to be careful. And we're
not just talking about
OMM, but sometimes
certain medical
procedures, right, they're
on a car accident and
they're unconscious,
right, any rapid sequence
intubation, right,
if they get intubated,
right, and somebody moves
their neck suddenly,
they might be at a risk
for spinal cord injury
due to AA instability.
Just a summary on the
cervical spine, right, so we
talked about width flask,
loss of cervical odorsus,
right, chronic degenerative
disease, dyscognetic
pain versus radiculopathy
versus myelopathy.
spondylolisis,
plutoniation, right,
it's going to be the
nerve root below,
right, so C5 is going to
affect the bicep, C6 is going
to affect the wrist and the
extensors, brachioradialis,
and again, remember about
what we said about the
C7, right, I was going to show
you a picture, but I don't
think that picture would
have made a good outcome,
right, so,
yeah, so you can just
imagine the picture
to help you remember
C7, right, what nerve
rate is being impinged
on, and the pattern.
MRI, and begin conservative
treatment, and then just
remember rheumatoid cervical
spondylitis, C1, C2,
subluxation, right, can
be very, very bad, that's
why we put it in here,
right, because we want you
to know it can be bad, any
kind of cranial manipulation,
right, can leads to
potential bad outcomes.
We have thoracic and
lumbar spines, right? So
we're going to talk about
a compression fracture,
right? Herniated disc,
discogenic pain, fundylolysis,
spondylolisthesis,
ankylosis, spondylitis,
spinal stenosis,
and corda equina.
So we talk about a
compression fracture, right?
So this is going to be
picked up on an x-ray,
right? So you do x-ray
and you're going to
notice that there's a
change in the height.
This is commonly seen as
people get older, right,
they get low bone, low bone
mineral density, right,
but maybe they have a
history of osteoporosis.
So what's going to happen
here is that you're
going to lose some of
the height within the
fracture, and that could
potentially lead to a
fracture that could be
caused second day to a
fracture. How do we pick
this up? Point tendinous.
Point tendinous is
going to be localized
to the area of the fracture and
it's usually over
the spinous process.
The thoracic spine is
very commonly affected.
You're going to have
increased kyphosis
and you're going to
have a loss of height.
So one of the surgical
procedures they'll
use for this is, we'll
talk about on the
next slide, is the
kyphoplasty, right?
So a lot of different
indications depending on who
the patient and their
ability to go for any kind of
surgical procedure, but
basically this is for anybody
that has any severe
pain after non-operative
treatment, right? So what
they do, they put a cavity,
within the cavity they put
a balloon that expands and
they put in bone cement,
right? And And what that
bone cement does is kind
of separate the vertebrae.
So it's kind of
separate the vertebrae
and kind of
maintain the height.
Compression factor is
usually clinical diagnosis,
but x-rays of the entire
spine need to be done to
assess concurrent spine
factors. And then depending on
what other symptoms they
have, if they have a history
of weight loss, right, now
you've got to be thinking
about potential for
malignancy, right, infection,
You may want to get the
lab work we talked about
before, they have osteoporosis,
you may want to begin
treating the osteoporosis,
and maybe doing some
physical therapy, getting
them into any kind of exercise
program where they can
build up muscle strength.
Lumbar disc herniation,
lumbar herniated disc, so
basically intervertebral
disc degeneration that begin,
where you have basically
a decrease on nucleus
propolisis, right, this is
basically inside the disc,
right, it's going to
impair the loading,
it's going to impair
the load bearing
ability, right, and
now the collagen is
going to turn into
the weaker collagen,
right, so that annulus
fiber that you have on the
outside is going to become
weaker, so this is going
to become weaker, and now
you're going to have the
inside content is going to
come protruding through,
right, so you're going
to have potential for
herniation, You can have
hypertrophy of the progette
joint, and you can also have
bulging discs, right? And
that comes from thickening
of the ligamentum flavor,
and we're going to see
that on the next slide.
So when we talk about the
herniated disc, we just
mentioned before the most
common area is going to be
either the paracentral or
the posterior lateral, right?
And that's because the
posterior longitudinal
ligament is the weakest,
right? So, when you have
an L4, L5 herniated disc,
that's why it's more
likely that the L5 nerve
root is going to be
affected and not the L4,
right? So, that goes back
to what we talked about
in the beginning, right?
L4, L5 is going to
affect the L5 nerve root.
So, we have the herniation
disc, the different
types of herniation, right?
So, again, the annular
fibers, right, we talked
about is going to be
disrupted, right? It's
going to be disrupted, and
when it gets weaker, then
the inside contents, the
nucleus propulsors is
going to come out and it's
going to potentially
impinge on the nerve root.
So we have degeneration,
degenerative, and we have
a normal on top. You can
kind of see the spinal
cord, and then we talk about
the ligaments and flavum,
you get the hypertrophy,
that can cause impingements
on the spinal cord, and
we talked about impingements
on the spinal cord is
going to lead you to having
myelopathy type of pain.
So physical is jammed,
again, observations, you can
get so much information
about a patient just by
looking at them, seeing
how they walk, are they
walking with a cane, with
a walker, are they walking
with a limb, palpate the
bone, palpate the muscles,
the sciatic nauseous
tendinous, and radiculopathy
type of pain, and
any kind of step-off
may indicate potential
for spondylolisthesis.
We're going to talk about that
later on, big word, right?
Spondylolisthesis is
basically the fancy way
of saying it's slipping
of the vertebrae.
Some special testing, for
this lecture, for this
presentation, I'm not going
to test you on these, but
they're good to know because
you never know which one.
you might see on the boards
but there's no there's a
lot of different texts a
lot of different resources
depending on the resource
that you're using they're
going to have different
testing that they do now same
thing we talked about the
cervical spine right of the
nervous now we're going
to talk about the lumbar
spine the nervous right
we have l3 l4 right l3 l4
remember you kick the door
l3 l4 kick the door right how
do you kick the door right
so well you don't really
kick the door, but you're
going to have a patella
reflex, right, that's going
to kick out, right, patella
reflex, and your tibialis
anterior is going to be
weaker, right, that's going
to be your motor, and your
reflexes, your patella tendon
is going to be diminished
as well, and sensation is
going to be on the medial
aspects of the ankle,
right, L4, L5, it's just the
big toe that's going up,
right, that's going to be
your motor weakness, right,
it doesn't really have a
reflex, so if somebody asks
you for L5 reflex, right,
chances are they either
mean L4 or S1, right, and
then L5, S1 is going to be
your peroneus longus, so
remember that card is external
rotation and inversion.
The ankle, right, S1
is going to be your
Achilles tendon, and
it's going to be in
sensation. It's going to
be on a lateral ankle.
This is all high-earth
stuff. It's good knowing
them now. If you know
one or two of them very
good, then it can kind
of help you out in
getting out the third
one. Just like we talked
about the C5, 6, and 7.
If you know C7 very well,
it's going to help you
out with the others.
Here's another diagram.
Again, different resource.
L4, kick the door.
Here we have the reflex.
We can pretend that
the door right here.
L4, kick the door.
Motor is going to
be the tibialic
anterior, right, so ankle
dorsiflexion, and sensation
is going to be on the inside.
And then L5 is going
to be on top, and then
S1 sensation is going
to be on the lateral.
And another diagram,
right, so same thing, it's
repetitive, but I want
to show you that there's
different resources
is very, very similar.
Sometimes it's some overlap,
maybe some differences,
but this is usually
general what you find.
How do we find a
herniated disc in
the lumbar? Again,
imaging is the MRI.
It's better than a CT because
it can also find other
pathologies, not just
bone pathology, but other
kind of pathology that can
mimic a herniated disc.
It's non-invasive,
we don't need to do
contrast, and there's
no radiation to it.
When we do a cat myelography,
we need to do contrast
into the back, and then this
is done for patients that
have a contraindication for
MRIs, and then there's also
the nerve conduction test
and the electromyography.
And those tests are
specifically more for
the nerve conduction,
to see if they're
coming peripherally
or becoming central.
So herniated discs, we all
probably know somebody that
has or have or had at some
point a herniated disc.
Basically, we always
like to use non-operative
treatment, 90% of
people, patients do get
better within a few
months, they do get better.
We modify the activity, we do
activity that
doesn't cause pain.
Maybe we can get them
on a bike, maybe we can
change up something on
the exercise program.
We can do some anti
-inflammatory, ice, heat.
Physical therapy, really
building up on the
core, core muscles,
lumbar strengthening, you
really got to stabilize
the muscles in the back.
And then we're going
to consider surgery
if they have any
neurological deficit.
deficit, if they have any
impingements on
the spinal cord.
Severe motor deficit and
definitely cordial screener
syndrome. If you have a
patient that you think
might have cordial screener
syndrome in the office,
this is the patient you're
going to send them to the ER
because you want to
make sure that they get
evaluated very quickly
by a neurosurgeon.
If they failed non
-operative treatment or if
they have any other
issues or every patient is
going to be different,
right, so you really
got to work, you got to
evaluate the patient.
If they have a herniated
disc with radiculopathy,
you might go in and
take out part of the
disc, right, that kind
of makes sense, disc
herniation, you go in and
take out part of the disc.
If you're really having
degenerative disease,
so DDD is degenerative disc
disease with low back pain,
then you're going to go
in and do a fusion, right,
so fusion has the pros and
cons that goes along with it,
and that's why the results
are usually inconsistent.
Uh, discogenic back pain,
right, so discogenic
back pain, right, um,
similar to what we saw in
the neck, right, it's
disc degeneration and wear
and tear, right, this
is wear and tear, you're
not going to have any
herniations, right, there's
going to be no herniations,
there's going to be
no impingements on the,
uh, on the nerve root.
No impingements on
the nerve root is the
same thing as saying
no radiculopathy.
Uh, pain is exacerbated by
certain movement, right,
whether they're bending
forward, sitting down,
sitting down for nine hours,
or eight hours, or they're
going to be something that's
going to be triggering
the pain, right? So any
kind of nerve tension testing
is going to be negative.
Radiograph might show that
there's some disc space
narrowing, right? And
the MRI is going to show
degenerative discs without
any significant stenosis or
herniation. All right, so
they have back pain, they
have pain, but there's
no stenosis, there's no
myelopathy, and there's no
radiculopathy. Thinosis,
there's no myelopathy, there's
no radiculopathy, none.
And treatment is usually
conservative, but
there are some operation
options available.
So for discogenic pain,
they have different
types of procedures
that can be done.
Usually for the radicular
type of pain, the most
common is commonly due
to like the herniation or
spinal stenosis. And then
basically what they'll do
is the most common surgery
for a non-pacific back
pain is going to be fusion,
right, so you're going
to do a fusion of two or
more vertebrae together,
right.
So what happened here
is you've got to think
what's the goal of the
surgery, right, you're going
to go to surgery, the
goal is to restrict any
kind of spinal motion
and it's to remove the
degenerative disc. That's
the goal of the surgery.
There's a lot of variety of
treatments and it involves
placing a bone graft
between the vertebrae.
So it's going to alter
the normal mechanic of the
spine. A patient might feel
a little bit more stiff.
They're going to feel like it's
definitely going to
have a difference in
how they move on a
day-to-day basis.
The American Pain Society
recommends surgery often
to patients with persisting
pain for greater than
a year. That's disabling
non-radicular lower back
pain. So again, non-radicular
lower back pain, right?
You have to talk about
the risks and the benefits
with the rehab team as well.
And so again, that's the
fusion for the discogenic pain.
We have some two big words, but
very important words, right?
First aid can tell
you that as well.
You don't have to
take my word for it.
Spondylolysis and
spondylolisthesis, right?
Try saying that 10 times
before you go to bed.
Spondylolisis is
basically a fracture.
It's a stretch fracture in the
pause, in sort of
ticularis, right?
So it's a stretch fracture,
right? How do we get a
stretch fracture? That can
be due to overuse, right?
So we might see this a
lot in, like, the younger
athletes, right? Something
where they're hyperextending
their back, right? Hyper
extending their back. Like
in a football player,
typically it's the linemen,
right? The people that are
on the front line, right?
and they're blocking, right,
so they're going to extend
their back. We see this
with the volleyball player.
We can see this with the
tennis player, right, that's
serving the ball. They keep
hyperextending the back.
And then if it gets
to a certain point,
right, you can also
have bondololithesis,
right? That's a nice way of
saying anterior flippings.
You might see a word
anteriolithesis.
That's a nice way of
saying lithesis flipping
anteriorly, so they go
back and forth, same thing.
one vertebrae on
top of the other.
So here's an example of
the pictures, right? So we
have a picture of pars
interarticularis over here.
Spondylolysis, right?
Again, this is a stress
fracture and this
is the clipping of
the vertebrae. So
here we can see the
vertebrae's clipping.
And here we can see
the stress fracture.
So we're going to
talk a little bit more
about the fungalolysis,
overuse injuries of
the lumbar spine that
come from increased
loading force on the
posterior elements.
So you get increased loading
force on the posterior
element. You get that by
extending your back. You
get that by being the
lineman on the football team.
Basically, it's the
pause into a ticklerus.
I say that a few times
just because it's
important to know. And
a repetitive extension
on the back. Usually
involve activities where
the lower back is
repeatedly hyperextended.
I forgot the gymnastics
folks, so definitely in
gymnastics you'll see this
potentially in dancing as well.
And then I'd mention
tennis, volleyball,
and football. You
have the linemen.
Usually the stress injury.
If you don't take care of it,
you keep doing activities.
it and make it a
stress fracture.
So spondylolysis,
right, workup, well you
gotta find out through
imaging that it's
there, right, so you're
gonna order an AP,
you're gonna order a lateral,
and you're gonna order
an oblique, right. We
order an AP because it's
gonna give you an anterior
posterior view, and sometimes
you can see if there's
any kind of scoliosis,
right, if you're looking
at anterior to posterior.
Lateral is gonna tell you
if there's one vertebra,
and then you have slippers
of one vertebra on top of
the other so now you can
see that this vertebra is
moving forward and this
is moving back so you have
slippers of the vertebra
that's how you see your
lateral view and then you're
going to get an oblique
oblique is going to be your
view that you pick up for
the spondylolysis right and
we're going to talk about
scotty dog because scotty
dog is important right so
we're talking about scotty
dog right here we have
a picture of a scotidoid,
or we have three pictures,
right?
Basically one is normal,
right? One has a collar,
right? That collar represents
a fracture, a stress
fracture. And then here we
have a separation, right? Not
good at all, right? We have
a separation of the head
and the body, right? No
collar, but this is your
spondylolisthesis, right?
Now this is going to cause
the slippage of the vertebra,
slippage of the vertebra.
And here we have the stress
fracture. So on actual
imaging itself, here we see
a normal scotty dog, this
is what we want to see. We
don't want to see a collar
on the dog, we don't want
to see any separation.
But here we see a normal
scotty dog right there,
but now we get over
here, we have an abnormal
scotty dog. We have a
dog with a collar on
it, that collar is going
to be the fracture.
How do we treat this?
Just like everything else,
For overuse injury, we
stop the activity, right?
Stop the activity,
give it time to heal.
Anti-inflammatory, Tylenol,
return to play based
on resolution of the
pain, right? So they've
got to be feeling better.
They can do some physical
therapy, consideration
for a breeze, and
they want to do a gradual
return to play, right?
That means they're not
going to play the first
day back. They're not
going to play in the
game, right? They've got
to get into practice.
They've got to get
into exercises relating
to the activity that
they want to be doing.
So we talked about
spondylolisthesis.
Spondylolisthesis is
going to be slippage
of the vertebrae, one
on top of the other.
Five major types, we have the
one that has abnormal anatomy.
Then we have the most
common one that we see in
the young athletes. We
talked about that being a
pause intersticularis
defect, a stress fracture.
That's where we
have spondylolisis.
Then we have the degenerative.
That's more common if we
get older. So if we get
older, the discs become
weaker, right? Weaker,
dehydrated, and now we
have degenerative. And
then we have the traumatic,
high-velocity injuries,
and we have pathologic
where we might have a
tumor or any kind of
osteoporosis, osteopenia.
Spondylolisthesis
may be asymptomatic,
or they may be symptomatic.
So you're going to notice
that there's a step-off.
This grading,
I remember knowing this
grading very well. This is
in that green book. We all
love that green book for
the OMM that we're going
to be studying when we
take the OMM coma in your
third year of med school.
It's good to know
the different grades.
Less than 25% is going to
be grade one, and that's the
most common. So that's the
most common, and it's also
the most mild. And then
the more slippage you have,
the more high, or
more high, but the
higher the grade
it's going to be.
So you'll see this at
some point, so it's
definitely worth knowing,
but it's kind of easy
to break it up, 25,
right, quartile, right,
I think the word is
quartile, 25 percent up
to 50 percent, 75
percent, and 100 percent.
All right, so I know you
all like questions, so we're
going to go through a couple
questions. I apologize.
I did go over a cumulus
bleed, right, but I could
tell you the DPR lecture.
I'm going to try to keep
that a little shorter, but
this is important, and I
think it's important to know
that I repeated a lot of
stuff, too, right, and I
repeated a lot of the stuff
because especially with
the nerve roots and the
cervical and the lumbar is
because, A, it's important,
and sometimes repetition
makes it easier to remember.
So question number
one, you have a 25-year
-old male, right, coming
to the office with
progressive little back
pain and stiffness.
He's been going on
for several years,
but it worsened over
the last few weeks.
Patients tried physical
therapy and over
-the-counter ibuprofen.
He wakes up and he had
morning stiffness to
last about an hour.
He also had some eye
redness and blurry
vision. So now we're
talking about back
pain, now we're talking
about eye changes.
And he had no rash urinary
symptoms or diarrhea.
He's afebrile. Limited
range of motion, so
he's a little stiff,
moving left and right.
Especially with our
forward flexion.
And here's some tendons
over the lumbosacral
area, so what do
you all think it is?
And you are all correct.
Very good. So the answer to
that is ankylosing spondylitis,
and usually the next
comment is, we never went
over that, and I would
say we're going to go
over it now. Right, so
ankylosis spondylitis is
an autoimmune inflammatory
arthritis of the
spine. So basically it's
more of a chronic, it's
more progressive back
pain that leads to like
a stiffness in the back.
It has reduced spinal
range of motion,
right, that's a
significant feature of it.
Usually it's in
somebody that's younger
than 40, it peaks
around 20 to 30.
Pain improved with
activity, so that's why
they feel pain in the
first hour of waking
up. And they also
have pain at night.
They also have some
other findings,
right, they might have some
SI, sacroiliitis, arthritis.
We mentioned in the
question to them that
there was lumbar sacral
tenderness, there
might be some reduced
chest expansion and
reduced spinal range
of motion, right, and
pulmonary compromise,
right? So if
you're not expanding
your chest,
your chest, you're going to
have some pulmonary compromise.
You might have some
tenderness at the tendon,
dactylitis,
swallowing of the fingers and
toes, and osteopenia
osteoporosis,
right? Potentially that
leads to fractures,
right? And that could
lead to spinal cord or
nerve root, right? So
again, spinal cord,
nerve root, know the
difference between the
two and the type of
symptom that they have.
Non-articular, right
outside the joint,
they're going to have
anterior uveitis.
That's the most
common, I would say.
Anterior uveitis,
that's why it's
highlighted in red.
It's probably the most
common extra skeletal
complication.
And usually that's
unilateral, eye
pain, blurry vision,
maybe photophobia.
You can also have
cardiac issues as
well, leading to
aortic regurgitation.
So you can do lab
testing on this
patient, right? So
you can do some lab
testing, you can order
an HLA-B27, right?
So HLA-B27, right,
HLA-B27 is basically a
test within the blood,
right? You can get a
blood test and more than
90% of the patients that
have AS have HLA-B27.
But not everybody
that has HLA-B27
automatically has
ankylosis spinolytis.
Bamboo spine, right?
So key word right
there, bamboo spine.
And that's a nice way of
saying fusion of the vertebral
body with ossification of
the intervertebral disc,
right? So ossification of
which is right here, that's
normal. And now we have,
you can kind of see that
it's all fused together.
Another question, we
have a 67-year-old female
coming to the office
with a little back pain,
difficulty walking for six
months. Pain is worse when
standing and it gets
better when sitting down.
The pain is less severe
when walking uphill and
it's less severe walking
uphill than it is walking
downhill. On examination,
there's no spinal
tenderness, negative
straight leg raise, reflexive
truplets in both legs, and
distal pulses are intact.
What is the most
likely diagnosis?
So we don't think that
it's a herniated disc,
we're not seeing any
reticulopathy, cortis
carina, there's no bowel,
bladder, incontinence.
The answer for this would
be your spinal stenosis.
All right, so spinal
stenosis is your narrowing
of the spinal canal,
or the neural foramen,
and that causes the
compression of the
thecal *** in the
central stenosis.
So basically you have
intervertebral, the disc we
talked about before, we get
older, the discs, they shrink,
and you get a herniation
that redistributes the
force of the vertebral
canal, and that puts a lot of
pressure, a lot of pressure,
a lot of loading, excessive
load on the ligaments and
flavum, right, and that
becomes thickened, right, and
I think that's a key thing
to know right there, that
ligaments and flavum becomes
thick, right, because it
has, it's bearing an extra
load, and it's hypertrophied,
and now that's going
to pin potentially on the
spinal cord, right, so that's
one way to get it. The
other way to get it, we have
bone spurs that develop,
right, through arthritis,
right, So we have arthritis,
we have bone throids,
we have ligamentum,
flavum, hypertrophy, and we
have intervertebral disc
herniation or shrinkage.
So the classic presentation
for spinal stenosis, very
important to know, is that
it's usually going to be an
elderly patient. They're
going to have low back pain.
They may get ridiculous pain
but it could be plus or minus.
What's going to happen
is, at the beginning of
the diagnosis, they're
going to start with a very
brief period of rest to
avoid any kind of painful
activities, and they're
going to pick up what
causes pain and what
makes the pain better, and
one of the things that
makes the pain better
is what is going to lead
to shopping cart signs.
So this is the, if you
go to, in New York,
we have ShopRite and
we have Stop and Shop.
I don't know what they
have in general, but if you
have the local food
market, then you'll always
see like an elderly person
leaning over the cart.
And when they're leaning
over the cart, they're doing
that not because they just
don't want to be there.
They're doing it
because it's helping
to relieve the pain
that they have in
their back that's due
to spinal stenosis.
So basically by leaning
forward, flexing, leaning
forward causes flexing,
increases the space and the
stamina, and that decreases
the compression. So when you
see somebody leaning over the
cart, that's the potential
that they're making their
back feel better, and
that helps the fingers
between vascular claudication.
And then also neurogenic
claudication, lower
extremity pain,
parathesia, weakness with
walking and standing,
and you always want
to consider peripheral
vascular disease.
So shopping cart shine.
We like pictures, right?
Pictures help, right? So
here, the ladies leaning
forward, sometimes they're
leaning forward a little
bit more, and that increases
the, that opens up the
space in the spinal, in
the spinal canal, right?
So again, imaging is going
to be x-ray, CAT scan, MRI,
can be used to confirm stenosis
with the proper clinical
finding and plan operative
treatment if indicated.
So usually it's going
to be x-ray first,
and then it's going
to be the MRI.
We're almost done.
Almost done. I apologize again
for running a few minutes late.
Corda esquina syndrome.
The spinal cord we know
ends at conus medullaris,
which is L1. But below
that level, you have the
nerve root that comes
down. So, again, this
is important to know,
and I emphasize the nerve
roots are coming down.
Why is that important to
know the nerve roots and
it's not the spinal cord?
Because if it was the spinal
cord, you would have a
whole different symptom.
You would have a whole
different symptom.
And what I mean by that
is that the compression of
this nerve root is going to
lead to placid paralysis,
Where if you were to
have something on the
myelopathy, on the spinal
cord, you would have
myelopathy and you'd
have ******* paralysis,
right? So that's good
to know, but it's
also good to know what
is flaccid paralysis,
right? Flaccid paralysis is
basically when your muscles
become weak, right? And
that happens because your
muscles shrink, it can
become flabby. where *******
paralysis is your muscles
become tight and hard, and it
causes your muscles to go
back and forth uncontrollably,
right? And that's your
myelopathy. That's because it's
impending on the spinal
cord versus the nerve root.
Why do we get cordasquina?
A number of reasons,
right? And it's a red
flag. Sometimes if you need
to rule it out, if you
think somebody might
have it, you're going to
send them to the ER. on.
But there could be massive
central lumbar deterioration,
not good, fracture,
trauma, epidural abscess,
hematoma, neoplasm, infections,
all not good, all stuff
that you just want to get
them evaluated quickly.
So, cortex guinas, again,
I repeat a lot of what I
said already because this
is very important to know.
Presentation, pain in the
lower back and the buttock
region. right, unilateral,
right, with severe radicular
pain, right, you're going
to have saddle anesthesia,
right, why do they call it
saddle anesthesia, right,
because you think of somebody
sitting down on a horse,
right, and they're
going to have
numbness in the inner thigh,
right, or numbness, decreased
sensation in the
****** perineal area,
loss of **** puncture and wink
reflex, bowel or
bladder incontinence,
urinary retention, and
we talked about flaccid
paralysis and decreased
lower extremities,
right? Again, these are
all signs of corda esquina,
right? Decreased lower
extremities, right?
Decreased, right? We talked
about for radicular type
of pain, where if it was
a spinal cord, it would
be increased reflex,
right? So we talked about
myelopathy would increase
your reflexes. This is
radiculopathy. This is
decreasing your reflexes.
MRI is the test of choice.
And then again, surgical
emergency, right?
Make sure they get
evaluated right away, right?
Depending on the area where
you're practicing, right?
So in Long Island, we have
a neurosurgeon at almost
every hospital, right? So
we're going to send somebody
over, and if they can't then
they get transferred over
and different parts of the
country that you have to know
where they can go and
get evaluated quickly and
hopefully within 48 hours they
can go get a decompression.
I'm not a radiologist
but I can tell you
how we can see the
pathology right there.
Okay so we're gonna wind
down a little bit. I
know it's been a long
afternoon, morning, evening.
So we're going
to wind down with
a summary, vertebral,
compression,
fracture, right, so we talk
about a fracture, right,
we got to find out what the
bone density is, right, we
want to make sure, do they
have osteoporosis, right,
are we going to treat them
for osteoporosis, they're
going to have point tenderness,
we talk about the lumbar
disc herniation, right, we
talk about the NPAF, the
annular fibers, right,
becoming weak, usually the
weakest point is at the
posterior lateral, and that's why
the herniation for L4, L5
is typically going be L5.
We talk about L4,
kick the door.
L5,
a door to flexing of the
ankle. You can also do
heel walking, which is
pretty much the same thing.
And then S1 is plantar
flexing and the Achilles.
Discoogenic pain.
Discoogenic pain is without
herniation or
reticulopathy. Then you
have spondylolysis,
right, looking for a
starting dog sign,
right, gematic, football,
tennis,
spondylolisthesis, right,
doesn't always have to
be anterior displacement,
but it can be. You're
going to have a step-off,
right, you're going to
have one vertebrae
slipping over the other,
ankylosing spondylitis,
HLA, HLA, B27, bamboo spine,
right, sacroiliitis,
uveitis, all important stuff.
spinal stenosis, any
degenerative narrowing,
and shopping cart, right,
that's why they get
better, they feel better,
they don't get better, but
they feel better when
they're leaning forward.
And then on cord excreta,
emergency surgical
decompression.
So lecture summary, be
familiar with the history
of physical and basic
imaging, right, there's
no x-rays, MRIs,
surgical spine, know the
mechanism, right,
understand the mechanism of
injury, understand the
mechanism of presentation,
and know the mechanism
and pertinent finding.
So we talked about the
thoracic, we talked about
thoracic lumbar, we talked
about kyphosis, we talked
about thoracic and
lumbar, lumbar herniation.
So in the interest of
time, we could stop
here, or if you guys
want to go through the
questions, we can go
through the questions.
If you do stop here, just make
sure to leave an evaluation
if you can. I know the
lecture was long, I do
apologize, but hopefully I can
make the DPR lecture a little
bit shorter for you all.
This way it balances out.
We try to make the
lecture a little bit fun.
Make sure you guys are
here for the DPR lecture.
I have three of them. I'm
actually presenting three.
One of them is already
done and I can't tell
you what it is but it's
going to be a fun one.
So question number three,
I'll give you a moment
if you want to just pause
and read the question.
And for those who want
The answer, those who
are saying the answer
is C, right, you all are
100% correct, right,
so you have spinal cord
compression between C1 and
C2, right, why is that?
Because we're thinking
about AA subluxation,
we're talking about excessive
movement between the
atlas and the axis,
right, we're talking about
the incompetency of that
transverse ligament.
And what else did we
talk about? We talked
about the upper cervical
region of the spinal
cord, right? Upper cervical
cord compressed between
C1 and C2, and that
can cause a lot of bad
stuff like quantaplesia,
right? So we talk
about quantaplesia and
potentially, it could
potentially be fatal.
So you can kind of
see from the family
telling you that
the patient has a
history of RA,
rheumatoid arthritis.
And I'll give you a few
seconds to read number four.
And what do you all
think the answer is?
And you're all
correct. Very good.
I'm very happy that you
guys picked this up during
the lecture. Alright, so
basically C5, C6 is going to
affect the C6 nerve root,
right, so when we talk about
the nerve root, we're
talking about weakness in
the right wrist extension,
right, so weakness in the
right wrist extension, and
you have sensation deficit
over the lateral right
forearm, right, again, lateral
right forearm, so that's
going to be your C5, C6,
Yeah, so the next question
is going to be the same
question, right, but it's
just going to check the
reflexes for C5, C6, what
do you all think it is?
And you are all correct
again, right, the
answer is the
brachioradialis, right, so,
The answer is the
brachioradialis, just to make
sure you read the entire
question, right, hypo
versus hyper, right, so
when you have a radicular
type of pain, right,
when you have nerve root,
right, it's going to
cause hyporeflexia. When
you have myelopathy,
right, you have spinal
cord injury, you're going
to have hyperreflexia.
So, again, that's
the brachioradialis.
Again, if it was
C7, right? Remember
what we talked about C7, right?
That would be the triceps and
references.
Again, leave the
feedback form. I hope you
all enjoyed the lecture.
Thank you for attending
the lecture. I know
you have a thousand
things to do, but we do
appreciate your time.
Hopefully it was very
beneficial, not just for now,
but for all the patients
that you see in the future we
do have three more DPR
lectures that are coming up
hopefully you'll be able to
make it otherwise good luck
with your studies and and
I'll see you soon. Thank you.